may the force be with Billy Dee Williams
82 year old actor is being showered with
love and support on Twitter after coming
out as gender-fluid
in a recent interview with Esquire Billy
opened up about staying true to himself
revealing quote I think of myself as a
relatively colorful character who
doesn't take himself or herself too
seriously to know that people appreciate
what goes on in the actor goes on to
tell the outlet quote you see I say
himself and herself because I also see
myself as feminine as well as masculine
adding I'm a very soft person I'm not
afraid to show that side of myself no I
know it's B's I'll take good camera she
won't get a scratch
Williams is set to reprise his role as
Lando Calrissian in Star Wars the rise
of Skywalker people keep asking me and
when he was told that Donald Glover who
also played Lando in so low a Star Wars
story discussed gender fluidity and
sexuality ahead of his debut and the
franchise Williams reportedly lit up
exclaiming really that kid is brilliant
just look at those videos here's what he
recently told et about returning to the
role and the skywalker series coming to
an end
I guess it's bittersweet I don't know
it's a wonderful experience I didn't
expect it do you believe that it's the
last one because I don't know if I do
they will probably go on for another 40
years
[Music]